welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name's Hisham azuz today I'm
joined by Jae Geun a who is the
associate director at digital gurus who
are a leading tech and digital
recruitment business that on an
international recruitment business
recruitment business they have offices
throughout the UK in australia and dubai
and jay works out of the monster office
and currently manages a team of eight j
thanks for joining me thanks for the
invitation
yeah been looking forward to it
obviously we're in the set the same nice
sunny day we're indoors recording it
remotely yeah thank you for that you
know choosing the hottest day of the
year so look we're always that to start
this podcast jay is and how did Jae Geun
a enter the world of recruitment let's
start there yeah so I I would say it was
a lot more kind of premeditated or
calculated than what say most recruiters
would say I don't subscribe to that I
fell into it why are you are willing to
do it and it all kind of started cutting
cups I mean I did TT ins abroad in
Magaluf so a good idea same level same
level of nastiness basically yeah
Travis 2011 it was there and we're all
going off to go anywhere in cyber clean
so after uni Danny
yeah so it's uni but at the end of that
the unions are samus that's where we
went for two weeks and what there were
in the pool and then I'm going off to to
Manchester to go do my master's degree
one best miss Tommy he's going off to
America to New York to be this yes a mad
title but it's gonna be a headhunter
another cosmetics and a career in I'll
get into his title mate it's mental
because yeah we're number guys let's go
see finance not boost you in the army so
enough let's do our separate things and
then just listening to Tommy because
this is where we'll come
listen sore talk about recruitment and
well it's about how much money is in
earning and I was thinking wow I'm gonna
go spend another two three years in this
master's degree I'm gonna probably have
two or three jobs at once working KC
Sports Direct just try and make ends
meet and this guy's really around
Manhattan doing what the hell he wants
yeah so yeah we kind of met up around
must be Christmas time later that year
he's absolutely rolling it and I'm
working in this Dungy bar back home I'm
just thinking what is going on in my
life you know go back to uni I mean
goggles on I've got the pets and
thinking this isn't greeting me like I
love I mean this is a genetics degree
just to get that in there yeah but I
love all that stuff but I just what this
isn't really me
right right so it just listen to Tommy
and the sort of things that he was
getting up to not just for your good
alright but the way me and you've been
brought up I've always been better than
you at stake I'm also a bit don't worry
I'm doing it that's it so yeah it kind
of comes towards the end of my Master's
Michael run the go for it now okay okay
so obviously had an interesting insight
into recruitment which was all the good
stuff let you can earn loads of cash I'm
smashing it what what was Tommy's title
then because they've got some mad tacos
in America man it's like a vice
president or something
I think he I think he's about now but he
started off as a high frequency high
frequency but ain't hurt unter presence
entry of technology also had I don't
know it was some mad metal and I just
member seen him walking up to beam Sonya
I'm this I'm that I'm just walk Oh God
although I think you're their kids yeah
I do admire that because you know
function yeah okay
so wanted to get into and recruit them I
guess how did you then end up what like
applying for a rhetoric or like what how
did you end up with Oscar did you have a
friend there or like how did you end up
there no when was I I was at you I was
at Union Manchester that's how I bumped
into this guy
he worked a company called red pepper
rhetoric okay just just got talking over
some beers and he goes again selling me
the drink recruitment yeah that's right
I know if you put my few businesses here
we go each kind of way from there really
got me in swass going yeah I never
really look back I guess alright so just
to say out for everyone you then work to
us before was it five years or just
under five years you know I think it's
about fall just on the fall yeah boy
it's a real real solid stint for your
first job in recruitment and then
obviously more recently been working
that digital gurus for coming up
obviously three years so just to set the
scene so just quickly on that so that
was got that four year journey from what
I can see online it was the typical join
as a consultant talent can son whatever
to sort of bidding leader or big manager
role by the time he left yeah okay cool
so we're always lot to sort of uncover
is like so J heard about Tommy and his
sort of experience so I'm sure that you
backed yourself and he was like you know
what I'm well up for this I'm up for
earning the cash paying off the student
there was it was the first year like you
know what it was easy
that's no it wasn't easy
like the money was very good it can vary
actually to me I should probably say
that the wrong part of it
so first year so it wasn't I was to let
you hear the stories right it's
difficult course of course oh but but so
okay let's talk about that then so why
looking back so first was you contract
perm what was the yep yep so I started
off as it was awesome something so just
want to feel jobs but my manager had
uncle its complete delivery contracts
here yeah but you know what that was
such a good in science of recruitment
because you know how quick contract
cream is it was it was
IT technology it was very very buoyant
very very quick with lots of clients and
you know it's been impolitic host was
busy you know I was there you know how
some they talking the more to turn up
overnight probably three times a week
four times a week and I loved it because
you know was getting the result
straightaway luckily you know no
different so that first year was it just
quickly
was used-- a complete delivery he won
focus on winning clients or winning
projects no so I think it was three
months in no sorry two months in I that
manager actually left a silk even
contact me now actually and I joined
another manager I was with him for four
weeks what what was the timeline say
just three months from being a trainee
to a console or four months when and so
four months in you then added DBD get
clients yeah so I mean the way also do
you think is the introduces of BT so I
pretty early on you know actually kind
of mastered that can decide so in
closing managing people for a process
once you can kind of document in
evidence that you can do that they then
introduce you into the BD side and being
subtly manages and perceive all the
other recruits in the room you you just
naturally kind of here help you can do
it yeah training scheme there as well so
you're doing things in practice and so
it's quite it's quite a good transition
yeah okay so looking back then J why why
do you think you was able to pick it up
quite quickly or why do you think I was
able to be quite effective quite quickly
do you think looking back my goals were
very clear and I needed money basically
it was very motivated very very
motivated around money I I knew I needed
X amount mates do X Y and Zed and at the
time that was by a car that was by house
I know these are probably things that
people here they are a million times and
you're right but if you nail down truly
in some motivations like how hard and
how much you really want that that's
when you probably get in the right
recruiting I suspect I don't know right
yeah no I knew exactly what I wanted and
you're luckily a very good manager at
time and he broke it down for me sir
okay
so if you want to help how much wasn't
spend the house now lived in Manchester
so it's not London prices right so it's
like 200 K whatever okay so what does a
deposit into it like Vijay
okay well probably 15 percent okay you
need 30 grand Jai right how do I get 30
grand keV I don't do it and then you
just go from there you
that's really interesting so very early
on you really reverse engineered what he
needs to do absolutely yeah I didn't
mind you know I had some help can get
into that yeah how do I achieve that
absolutely and it's and I think it's
something that I've laid out so the guys
are trained and I think that's awesome I
think that's great because it's it's
very easy to say that as you said Jane
like he owned a home run by my folks
probably blah blah blah but and then
it's the that next level where you know
each week or what the actual numbers are
what the actual outputs or activity or
actual outcomes that you need it's gonna
get you there yeah what it's a word did
you end up building in your flesh here
then remember yes first year was 200
pretty much in the notice really yeah
not bad is it yeah I've never really
done much more to be fair yeah I'm not
the world's best recruiter but 200k yeah
well that was contract day at first you
know so for the first month two months I
started off on contract resource and I
moved on to perm oh sorry yeah sorry so
always been a perm
okay so that's interesting then actually
so just going to think of it on the
contract side can that delivery and then
transition to permanent okay cool I
didn't realize that that's interested
yeah no okay
so just quickly before we move on hmm
how much of an impact did your
environment have on Jay the recruiter do
you think like what looking back
anything that maybe you heard that had a
big impact on you or certain advice that
you received quite ideal and that had a
big impact on you I love the fact that
sort of you had a manager that actually
really broke down what your goals are
think that's awesome but anything else
looking back because I think that's a
lot of thing that's going to be
interesting with the time right now like
if you think about Jae Geun a the person
who's really motivated come out of uni
joins a recruitment business tomorrow
it's gonna be way more difficult to soak
up like everything that's going around
from your office at home in your
bedrooms you know I mean so like what
how much of an impact do you think that
that environment has on you
I would say had a big impact I think you
know and I appreciate this is why maybe
some recruiters right now working
remotely or somewhere struggling and in
that environment I was surrounded by
people who may be like-minded maybe have
different motivations but it all
centered around getting money so go and
enabled them to do things and I think
when you have that common goal and there
is that team mentality you're all sat
there till eight nine ten o'clock at
night thinking I don't want to be here
I'd rather be in the booze are down
there or up the carb up there whatever
that looks like but you know it's the
longer-term goal here so we're doing
this for a reason here here's that
sourcing getting these getting
references to quench house RBD for the
following day in the following week
looks like so yeah I think is that
commonality and we so out Oscar we we
did not train in Academy so it wasn't
just you that was a trainee you probably
knows that really yeah that's what I
mean so you know we probably all end up
going down to the booze or at ten
o'clock at night so that really helped
that togetherness what was the best
piece of advice you think you got early
on the best piece of advice yeah in that
first year you think I think it was just
look things will get difficult things
will get hard but just just remember
water here mmm and I think that's always
kind of stuck with me because you know I
know it's like you could be sat there
thinking sometimes you work here and
sure you get it as well where you just
think you hit yeah you start considering
things that we all have that little blip
we thing but I think as long as you kind
of think about so why am I in this game
why am i doing this and what was your
wide end this is it was as simple as I
want to buy home on these things that
were there you're sort of anchor points
yeah I mean I'm not going to sob story
anything backgrounds right it's a bit
that's a bit painful but I've never had
money
you know we've my family of always done
alright but we'd never have money to go
and do things and you know I've never
gone luck off even a freestyle holiday
to be yeah but I have been on holiday so
I've not been treated badly
and so I want to go and do these nice
things in life but I genuinely wanted to
and I was willing to work hard for it
and the house goal you know I just
wanted that under me ASAP and I think
what's a twenty five six twenty five
I've always Drive banners as well
Barriss and bangers and like working in
recruitment yeah my friends heard you
know money I was earning and I'd remind
them but then I turn up in a Vauxhall
Vectra you know so the next thing the
next goal was this get let's get the car
let's make sure that yeah
there was always things yeah yeah and I
love that so going into year two then
what was the path for J still very much
billing consulting and that was what you
was focusing on or when did you start
taking on some leadership
responsibilities I think I think maybe
seven months in into being or sorry
maybe six months into being a consultant
yes I've been at Oscar maybe nine months
of this point okay I was given an intern
just I'm sure it's just a bit of PR to
the only but just just to get a bit of
interest into the recruitment world
right yes yeah what do you saw like
mentor then absolutely yes so you know
she said she sat with me every day we
put a three-hour training academy
because all right okay its recruitment
but there's many more skills and you
learn in this game just general life
skills so yeah I had out for three
months and I don't know done a good job
with her so I was entrusted to have a my
first training my first future trainee
really yeah that happened quite a
dealing so is that something that you
was you wanted like I've always known
not I've waited to go into management
really there's there's nothing more of
that pleasure to me than seeing someone
that I've kind of nurtured and pull
through go and do well there's no it
better yeah well better than you bill I
think I would love it if they do better
than me like my ideal yeah is that we go
and hit target so let's just say 20k
among for me alright but then they will
go to 20,000 100 quid all all well yeah
if they do more than me and I hit target
you know that's the I'm sleeping well
know
it's interesting isn't it why do you
think that is because like to get to
that to get to that point it will J had
to focus on gauge not I mean but then to
sort of really get it and its really
common thing that you hear but to get
that real buzz from other people when
typically it's yeah like you're you're
putting in the work and it's sort of
appreciating the what you put in and the
results that you get but so commonly to
say that I was finger to but I guess the
way of positioning do you play sport
football anything yeah yeah yeah so
let's just say it's the cup final right
you're injured you can't play but you
team go out there and they win why are
you sad you upset or you buzzing because
yeah absolutely buzzer yeah buzzer and
that's how I apply to this mmm you know
if you if you lot of winning on with it
yeah okay so I think a common challenge
that people face NJ is is this sort of
transition or that experience or that
learning of okay right I'm pretty decent
below back myself to do that I'm
confident with that but now I've got
someone else to be responsible for my
target still the same yeah so what what
was that transition like how difficult
was that that that wasn't easy but I
would say the naivety I didn't know
anything different so it was what it was
and but yeah it certainly had its
challenges but again you know I think
with because we did have a training
pedaling so there was all that
theoretical stuff going on the
background that did maybe alleviate
something left my time but don't get run
you know this out with you 9 hours a day
so it's hard so you have to make sure
that you've got enough pipeline yourself
and I think what helps is initially when
you bring on a trainees welcome from my
experience when you bring the trainee
they typically work the roles so they're
out that they are actually probably
adding benefits you in the phase out of
it
so yeah so you get one obviously
delivery and supporting the role yeah
there was it you put on good and I think
what helps it as well from from their
perspective so that they're bought in is
there seen success very very quickly and
think wow okay so like the hype is real
you can learn you very very quickly yeah
brilliant
and this and this looks easy and it does
you know if you look at recruitment from
the fire it does look very easy looks
like a couple of emails for the couple
of phone calls and you know you're
earning some good money
so I think prints the kind of experience
that early on and then I see my old MB
which you said to me make sure you get a
few deals make them feel the love make
them see the dream mm-hmm okay so then
what did you then grow that team further
then or what did the what did the
finished product it like and also so I
bought I got my first training through
and the kind of model that we had was
you dumped them onto your patch your
vertical and then you kind of progressed
them to something else
then you bring in another trainee don't
answer that
he's keep building from just quickly
sorry just quickly so to buy him no
because I think that would be a lot of
people how they approached here what was
because I'm sure you got better at this
what was like what was the things that
had to be in place or where did you have
to get to you for you to go right this
guns the next place or let's get someone
dedicated to that
so then move on to the next thing my did
you have to get have X amount of clients
do you have to be billing XML what was a
sort of trigger point or milestone that
you had to work towards ago right let's
get another person and I start folks and
this other sort of vertical that I've
already identified one what was the sort
of trigger point it's a good question I
don't feel it was an official trigger
point I think you know as long as you're
you know a profitability level very
sustainable for maybe bring on someone
that's going to cost you X amount of
money for x time then you can probably
say right this let's take that
associated risk but I think I think we
were well primed for it and when we were
junior managers so we knew it was always
going to happen that we're going to
bring on other people so when you're
considering that you're always trying to
look at other other towns at the cities
to try and build that up yeah so like
well in your head what was you like
right if I get like I don't if there was
anything but like I know like there's
not many exact science but if you were
like why if I get X amount of clients
that we've done X amount of placements
with like was you looking for that sort
of stuff too
you to be confident enough to be a lot
right it's got someone deliberate yeah
they're definitely to be some sort of
confidence that because we normally
although we try and keep two attacks
that because we do technology
recruitment yeah you don't technology
recruitment and it was geographically
driven as well so I think suggest to
give me some contest I think it makes it
easy to answer the questions so I see
the MIT mismatch and I'm Hitler this is
a huge geographic area you've got balmy
and you've got Lester Darby Natyam yeah
straight away you can probably split
that into three just geographically so I
think as long as you had maybe two or
three
you know reliable clients that you know
probably pigeonhole twenty thirty K a
year out of them you know that's going
to be circa what sixty-two undergrads
guaranteed yeah you know you know that
they're gonna be a case out on that so I
think was like I say there's no official
trigger yeah okay I think as long as
your beading was like that sort of level
you know it makes sense and then so then
what and then what did what did that
then get to them as you put that out
before you left
what does it get to yes some mushrooms
interesting Oscar like I was very driven
to kind of do more and more and more and
what that meant is I kept on saying to
my MD I was like let me do this patch
let me do that patch give me more give
me more
and ultimately you know we've smoked
about this since ultimately agreed to
shoot me a little bit foot because I
never really got to grow my team to you
know ten twenty thirty people because of
that why did you always want more did J
just want to be winning business is that
what is out what you love done yeah yeah
I was a bit of an emotional beast back
then I really I think you know in
hindsight wasn't really truly ready for
management probably not because you know
there was always that feeling of I've
got to give up half Apache what's that
about I'm gonna lose X amount of revenue
right what a nightmare but I wasn't in
the bigger picture and to be fair
they've done done right by me they come
and give me a little bit to kind of go
out and go and do something else but I
did eventually move on so I see support
infrastructure and started leading that
team and I think that was about ten
strong at some point nine attention all
but that wasn't really organic that was
I took no that's what you're inherited
in here is your five people and in grew
it by another five really yeah
so what did people always interest in
this and I was getting messages about
this Jay so like I'm assuming before
that point team of five or bigger
whatever so like did you still have like
what was your role then was it to bring
on clients win business help feed a team
help that or was it just was it you was
you non billing at that point of view
was your ways billion I was I was that
horrible billing manager it's the
hardest rolling recruitment I don't care
what anyone says no care of you to CEO
is it's the hardest role in my opinion
yeah so yeah I was still a building
manager so how and the question is sorry
too but inmate is just like how did you
maintain because like you but you will
put like clearly you're someone that
will put that pressure on yourself you
know what you're capable of you know
what you can do how did you maintain
your Billings or did you maintain your
Billings when you're inherit that team
was your you're growing the different
patches whatever like how did you ensure
you did that how did you stretch your
day like what what were you doing on a
daily basis weekly basis to ensure you
gave yourself the best possible chance
of doom we needed today yeah yeah so I
was on the team every morning 8 o'clock
okay and then we start half a glass but
where we got to West business on see you
know you said deploy I've been yeah I
think they give us a business to be fair
like a tracker system so okay yeah so
you've got X amount of clients all right
now where you got to this job okay
interview talk to you about the
candidates where they ought to talk
about their other interviews why Trina
get a job so I'd be all open from that
perspective from it so I want 8:00 in
the morning
well between eight and half eight you
know 13 to 10 it's going to take a bit
time yes you go through that yeah yeah
and then that will then give me more
time to go and do my stuff but you know
I think at the time and you know running
a team as 9/10 people I think kind of
train either side of me so yeah I was
like that was very very difficult but
again you know I referred to it the
start I didn't know any different I just
yeah yeah that's it yeah so I couldn't
sit there and get yeah I get lemon
Evalia or get annoyed it was just it's
just what you do so yeah it wasn't easy
um but I I'm able to give myself enough
time to still do my own things
and luckily my client portfolio was
large enough to help sustain me like yes
did your did your first so was your
first year your best year then Oscar mmm
no I think second or third member
they will stayed around to 250 yeah okay
alright so I guess just quickly before
we move on to lot more recently which
one keen today hmm
back then maybe you can now see the
first this now because you might have
applied it whatever but what do you wish
you knew about management before you got
into that how to separate yourself from
being friends with you know you can so
Angie you're calling this yeah into
being that that person that is you know
not just kind of trying to drive the
guys forward or anything like that but
having to be that [ __ ] at times and
you know that that was one thing that I
really do struggle with but really did
I've got some very yeah so my best mates
were cos I still do
so that was very difficult so it yeah so
yeah like so if you were really sort of
taught and now down on right Jay yes
that's okay and it's a positive that you
can build a good rapport good
relationships with your people and then
oh you've got your back and that may
mean that you may be seen as a friend at
time but Jay makes sure that there's
people know where the line is or know
that you are friends but the when I do
this or when I say this by my blood this
is like that's that's the manager I mean
that's what needs to be done yeah
absolutely yeah that's that's what I had
to learn and I probably learn it the
hard way at times but I know the
directors are certainly on on my back
about that too so you need to start
stepping away from it and you know got
to the point where you know I stopped
kind of going on certain nights out all
the things out because I couldn't be
seen you know to be going really or
whatever so yeah yeah okay
so join these two gurus so obvious a
good career there and so digital gurus
and so you've been there for tuna bit
years then did you join them straight as
a billing manager again or what was the
give me a bit of context yeah yeah yes I
mean the reason why I went to leave
Oscar was just purely because I was
bored of contingent recruiting them spot
business and I was adamant that I had to
go and learn things about MSP RPO
retained business elsewhere the reality
is I could have done it there but I just
you know once you've got something set
in your head
I see how house was big on Brandon I
thought if you had a better brand it'll
be better or easier to win business
you'd be maybe treated a little bit
differently so yes so joined digital
giri's it's like the obvious choice for
me yeah I joined us as a bidding manager
again a relatively small team at start
so just quickly because I think it's
interesting hands what was spoken about
it for a little while and I appreciate
being honest and the reasons for leaving
and I love that but I guess like you
know you know how is Jay like if you're
a recruiter and you've got two years
free is even like you had four he's
experienced you are valuable property
mate and you begin hit up left right and
sent them from retzor eggs like Joe got
this opportunity for Wii blah blah blah
right so I guess obviously I know you
said that the disagree was it was an
obvious choice but as you said like it
can be really quite difficult to know
what's out there what the other
alternatives are what compare things to
if you just worked one agency right it
can be really quite daunting to make the
right row and tip like typically I'm
sure you've seen it when you interview
people for your team or previously that
you see a lot of people on sort of
LinkedIn on their CV where they might
work to Oscar or whatever business for
two years three years leaving that
leaves end up working it for a couple of
months and then another agency or
whatever cuz it's not quite what you
hope so I guess like great position that
you're in nearly free is there so
obviously a great choice but I guess
what were some of the things that you
really fought about or sort of helped
you make a better decision during that
period because no doubt your head would
get sound a lot you know I mean so I
don't know what were some of the things
that were really important so you
mentioned there the Brandon or a
business that really sort of focused on
retained or whatever but what what did
you do - looking back like what was some
of
you really looked for or made sure that
you were where the case when you're
looking for your next role as you
progress in yes we're not when I left us
close but yeah it was for the right
reasons and I think if you are looking
at another opportunity you have to
understand what's right for you now
sometimes you don't know what they yeah
I fully accept that I think you had to
try and tune into what what's right for
you so what was right for Jake at the
time was I wanted to learn more I'm
going to learn different types of
recruitment it wasn't just about
contingent spot business I want to learn
about retained business I want to learn
about different solutions and have the I
guess the freedom and training to kind
of go and deliver that and I think when
I looked out to the market that's my
primary focus yeah those three
businesses that I kind of come across
that were really pushing that you know
and then I fought second yeah
secondarily what what else is important
to me and like I say it's its brand it's
is this an attractive round if I was a
if I was a software developer or a web
developer or digital marketer whatever
that looks like who would I be more
inclined to to contact or maybe take a
call off if I knew who that person works
for and the other brands were I would
maybe call corporate and that's fine
that's absolutely perfect you know the
brand I use work for was a bit more like
that and but I just felt for me the
brand was just a bit just a bit better
of me it made me feel a bit more
comfortable if you will I think it
suited my approach to things and just
out of interest how did you then look
for that in the interview process
because like you like John I mean
because like you can look it on the face
of it blah blah blah but what was
something yeah you know I mean what was
some of the important things that you
try to look for or made sure that you
understood or whatever like before you
made that decision to lead a job that
use obviously knew how to do yeah good
good people around liked you know I mean
like what are the important things that
made you more confident about choosing
that oh yeah sure sure yeah so I think I
posed a question to the three bits
little insecure and if you was let's
just say I was a client okay
and I said to you
why should I choose you to work with you
but what's different about you compared
to every other agency like give me your
answer so that and to be fair all three
businesses we're yeah in terms of what
they're trying to do which is a bit
different I was like okay right you'll
take that box and starts at first II get
into sense a good question
yeah and I think you know if it aligns
fantastic like you can always get sold
the dream can't you and yeah that's a
great question to ask isn't there I
think someone just quickly before you
move on something just because it really
resonated the Picasa did yesterday with
but heats the way that the way that he
coined it was really good is Jay tell me
what you're unfair advantages yeah it's
a great way to put that now I think that
as awful as class to be a gotten gone
through it so you ask that that's that's
a great question to ask
yeah and for me at that point I think
the digital Geary's answer was you know
and it's not just words you make
actually substantiate your claim as well
yeah say whatever the hell you want
really
but you need to substantiate and they
definitely could and I think secondarily
well if primary secondary you know it's
the people yeah I left an environment
where is very much raaah sales and
that's great you know I love that cool
but do I want to employ people into that
environment it's not everyone's gonna do
well and other people do when other
environments so and the people it's very
much important to me and you know I've
got to know the guys the squad's a DJ
and yeah they're good guys I think
that's fair like Jay the recruit at the
beginning of his career two four five
years down the line is different line
and what you want an environment and
people gonna be around this it's
different right and and changes so okay
the name of that person like James
blackwell got put on there because I
feel so bad if I didn't say that James
black or unfair advantage [ __ ] love
that okay it's a moot additional gurus
then and was it the same sort of market
was like what was the crack with that
was it did you then afternoon learn any
market did you have to do different
niche
what was the what did he end up focusing
on there yeah so it different market in
terms of geographic so okay the
Manchester office we only really do
managed your leads we just stick to the
north
yeah there's same sort of job tiles and
business yeah yeah yeah same same kind
of tech stacks and when you're new
businesses you have covenants coming out
your backside so you know I can take
anything with me if you already
candidate so in a way it's a completely
different market so because it was
geographically completely different and
did you inherit a team then was that the
yeah so you immediately I think I I get
three people think it was that were very
much gone you got something that's right
so there's three people that kind of I
guess lined up exactly as to what I do
what I recruit for so just make sense to
and happen how experienced were they one
was probably six months at a time
the other one was probably in tech
recruitment maybe nine months to a year
and the other that probably about the
same put about no no war just come to
mind I was there
what would did would the Jade do when
you joined to make sure that you're not
that new manager on the block coming
into a bit do not I mean because I think
that's also something to me that can be
quite daunting as well in it like that
you're gonna and inherit a team like cuz
yeah gone for more ever knows who I am
makes for most people blah blah blah
like well how did what was your mindset
going into that no swagger I didn't walk
in there saying I'm the big man I can do
this I can do that and first thing I
don't way now to prove myself and I'll
always give advice if you ask for it I'm
not going to force it on you yeah and I
just go in there show them what I can do
initially even though the job titles
there and officially there's lines of
people reporting in to me it doesn't
matter I've seen people come into
businesses trying to be big I am and you
know unfortunately that generally
doesn't work from what I've seen for my
speed yeah your mentality was very much
that right let's go in there premise try
it's not not sort of push how I do
things and anyone and be open because I
think that that can be a real big
challenge from a hiring perspective of
all is Jake and understand how we do
here at digital gear is Izzy
be open mind it's how we do or is he
gonna turn around so I love done always
like this Oscar no one do not I mean yes
did that come quite natural to you then
yeah I mean I'd say so yeah yeah don't
get me wrong livers things that maybe we
done at my previous business that was
different to what we do here at digital
gurus and I understood that's a positive
because there's things that we don't
also go to absolutely brilliant and
those things that we've done it DG
previously that weren't very good so I
think if you can marry her--too up and
you get a sweet middle ground in here
yeah I think that was kind of my goal
there if you will just to kind of bring
that how did you do that first year than
Jay my first year was was a stranger him
to Atlanta I think well firstly I have
my I have my little man really born yeah
thing is born what four months after I
came I got you in now sorry but yeah so
he's what about six months after I
joined but in the same time period and
the regional director who I joined under
she saw so definitely pregnant really
actually maternity leave so I actually
moved into this slide into him Regional
Director role for six months so man all
the pipeline that blew up everything
kind of I didn't pull through or
anything like that but you kind of had
to go window focus yeah you have to
focus another thing of different
priorities 1718 people that yeah that
was something to try and lead and manage
everything else it comes along with that
so that was certainly a learning curve
what was what was most challenging about
that so I think I said that start when
did you did you one did you want that
role by the way yeah I'm career driven I
you know some people say oh I'm not
really asked about tiles I am I'll be
the janitor but give me the MD title
I'll be cool with here by home no III
encouraging and say to kind of I think I
was ready to do something like that and
doing an amazing job now do you know
what honestly no but you know what I'll
give it a good go yeah my potential
issue is of six months in yeah I've
proved my stripes are showing that I can
do the job well I think my team have
grown to maybe six at the time or
something like that and you know
people brought in so I could do but it's
very early to say right yeah and I was
Julian that's yeah he's now managing the
Minister office yeah yeah so I was very
very conscious of that but again you
know I think everyone's very very
different so you can't hit people with
the same brush you can't treat everyone
the same the cop you certainly can't
managing the same so I think that's
where I really blew up some strong
relationships and people try to
understand what they're really about
what's their drivers what's the
motivators why you here what you wanna
do and went where do you struggle if
your business right now
can I help you and yeah you know I think
that's what kind of really helped me
move up the food chain a little bit mmm
that's awesome and loether plan you just
put your hat in the ring on that
especially six months into new business
as well right absolutely love that
that's that's no joke I guess with it it
might be an internally or whatever but
would like did you did you seek help
when you wanted it or needed it light
light you know I'm in yeah never be too
proud to ask for help yeah you know I'm
not that guy if you ask me a question I
don't know the answer I'm not gonna blog
yeah most of the time yeah I was
certainly gonna try and find the answer
and I think the best way to answer is to
call someone that has the knowledge so
yeah there was time to win our director
will come up and maybe once once a week
just to kind of help the things
alleviate some of the pressure that was
on me yeah so and then and then so then
do you end up then going back back to
the team that you was at after or what
how does that then sort of end up
turning out yeah so I mean within a few
months of that finishing once once Tony
the Regional Director came back within a
few months I was then promoted to to
what I am now associate director so I
was about even to be in there I guess
and so yes I think fundamentally and you
know my remit now is to ensure that we
hit 30 percent bit that's that's all I
have to try to achieve so well your
would you remember that your team yes so
it's a my division yeah so a people
but also a familiar support and
leadership to the other side as well and
all the rest of it when you say first
then you talk about a bit done sorry
yeah yeah so it's all about
profitability so we had to keep a cut
above the line there's a few reasons why
but you know essentially I was kind of
given freedom okj you can go and bill
and do a number and get it in to where
they need to be or embrace them try and
bring them on more get them to do more
and you win the business whatever that
looks like and get him set number if not
higher so that was the route that I
opted for I'm still posted you know and
alright number last year and yeah why
did you offer that room why yeah because
there's no for me is there's no
sustainability in me just go ahead being
a lone wolf from going at wind business
and go fill it all myself that's great
for me that's great for Jay but I'm here
to grow a team I'm here to go up the
food chain
alright one day I want to be imagine
director in the business if I'm just
going to have this single-minded
approach as an entrepreneur okay that
works but if you're looking at growing a
team to me it doesn't work okay so yeah
that's why I opted for it you know how
much did it help you understand then
what like that's really I love how they
communicate to you like like Jay this is
this is how profitable you want your
team to be that you don't normally hear
Billy managers say this is what this
this is the number we need to hit for ie
but that you don't normally hear that
you know I mean how did that help you
how do well I think it just it kind of
been granted in the business doesn't it
because you mean the business being very
open to you around numbers profitability
yeah so then all of a sudden you feel
like you have a real strong allegiance
this business that being very open view
and and I think without you you then
accept accountability which is a very
very powerful word in recruitment for
sure you know yeah so yeah I know what
our division or our office needs to hit
in order to do XYZ so yes also noting
that I think that's that's really
interesting that I think cuz again it
does get you in thinking as a business
rather than Jay in my teams you know I
mean when you are absolutely numbers
like that I think nothing that's really
interest in so just just quickly and J
what I guess what I'd like to sort of
just think about for a sec two things
one one of the most common things I get
asked about jazz is business development
because that can be one of the areas
that that's really challenging for a lot
of people and obviously you obviously
been leading people and intended for a
little while now so I guess from your
perspective what what are the typical
sort of pitfalls recruiters make that
you see the struggle with business
development do you think good question
stuffing there's a there's probably a
few elements and again I'll probably
just provide a bit of context to help
answer that question because I could
just talk about my own pitfalls and I
would say right earlier in my career
relationship building although it was
extremely important wasn't really the
emphasis it was all about slap wallet
manpower get the cell gets out right
yeah get a job home absolutely and
that's great but longer-term I'm sure
you'll get onto the cogut because it
relates to it longer-term if you're not
building those relationships
there's no sustainability or longevity
mm-hmm so I would say the only
relationships were probably the thing
that and maybe should have concentrate a
little bit more earlier on and in terms
of BD but thing is where people probably
yeah and again I can't talk for everyone
but just from what I've witnessed what
I've experienced like if I went onto my
phone but now right and let's not do
this by the way but if I just kind of
flicked on to someone and I gave that
personal kawar could probably say the
name their dog or something like that
okay that's unique that's the sort of
thing you trying to get into cuz I
wasn't that was um in my next question
Jay how can you how can you measure if
your gain in and having better
relationships of clients and prospects
how can you measure you know again I
think we were talking earlier about if
you have a crack daddy what can you do
so this the answer relates to that all
right so the way I measure it is if I'm
having a crap day right
forty people so maybe twenty can that's
funny clients I think just cool well I
know they're Lance and they'll see JQ
naming in they'll answer it
alright and we'll just have a great chat
okay
it picks me up no end so I think I hope
you're that kind of on yeah yeah yeah
yeah that makes sense because it's it's
more than a recruitment relation light
it's you know I mean it's a bit more
than ah who's this guy calling me this
about job I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure
they're also thinking that so a common
challenges issue that people are can get
caught up a bit early on or get caught
up in that whack wallet bang of right on
a job that's what this because rather
than thinking long term longevity
sustainable relationships with clients
candidate yeah potentially and I think
you know sometimes people trying over
complicate what the job is I don't think
you need to do that and there's loads of
different approaches interviews and then
I think you just got to find the one
that doesn't always necessarily feel
right initially but works best for you
so I've on the back I'm a big advocate
do you honesty we are quite likely
honest theory and it's it's one meal
awesome lots of quiet what do you mean
by the understeering so I just talked
about the reason why they're in and you
know there's there's the whole
references for me that kind of comes
into the honesty group so I know you
know this person I did I know them too
this is what we've done I'd like to do
that with you typing have you want to
spin it really and very very strong
honest indirect absolutely like the and
when it comes to beanie cause I know you
know ninety percent of the time people
don't that that BD called I get it
isn't it so much better if you go and do
some sort of warm reference cool
something like that where you just spark
a very honest and the easy conversation
and build on from there on this no this
isn't an this conversation today with a
business owner saying even like in the
current period right now like just think
there's just so much opportunity on in
gaining leads on the on the reference
inside
and I know it's like a proper classic
collide training thing like yeah like
you can get reference and gain leads or
whatever but like when you're saying
that Jade you just had a bit of context
that I know it sounds really simple
basic but people really like when you're
talking a bit more detail long the basic
stuff but when you say gaining leads or
successful BD being honest on the
reference in front you're just talking
about literally you're doing that when
you've placed someone or you know I mean
like what's what just give it add a bit
of context in a bit of detail to that
because I just think people listening
will just get quite a bit of value out
of there yeah I think every every
situation is very different so I can't
give you like a yeah but I guess kind of
a good example is that so you're
speaking to it doesn't really matter
what your mark is but for me they say
it's a front-end developer yeah so I'll
give that person a call I would find
some sort of commonality between me and
that person so maybe it's a business
agreement you work for the tech meetup
that they go to maybe they're into
football tonight yeah and some sort of
commonality for now and from there I
will find a link and it's normally from
a business that they work for previously
in that particular example and then at
that point I would say okay well I trust
my networks would be good enough to know
at least someone that's worked there
specifically in Manchester
yeah and I'll talk about that okay so
yeah and start building up the core okay
I think this if there's one thing you
should always remember all right that
front-end dev you're talking to right
now
alright that person might be a seven
eight round thing and that's it okay
cool
but in three four years time maybe less
that person might be a need from in
depth they might be a head of
development engineer CTO start their own
company
so that's why it's so important that the
relationship part right and having that
mentality yeah and then and then a
couple of things I want asked before we
finish today but just on this point
you've worked with different people
seeing different people manage different
people common common pitfalls in
recruiters that you you think common
pitfalls you seeing recruiters that you
think prevent them from taking their
performance to the next level yeah so it
it depends what level we're talking
about I think if you're talking out more
junior grad level and I think it's when
they truly actually want to do the job
yeah and what I mean by values
understand the motivations for why
they're doing it so that's sometimes a
bit of people how many times have you
seen it look maybe three to six months
people drop out because they realize
they don't actually work that hard for
that money
yeah so that's really fasting and I
think probably the big thing I've seen a
more experienced people is that aptitude
or winning this to learn no I have had
the pleasure of merging some very very
diverse people in my time and the
commonality or the common trait is
normally around that openness to learn
because I don't like being told they're
wrong I don't like being sold a room of
course not but and I've seen people grow
from hundred K builders to you know
three maybe four hundred K builders just
because they're taken a little bit of
advice which normally they wouldn't be
so much open to so you I mean I think I
said at the start you know when when I
took that into him role as an RD I knew
I'm not going to be amazing at this I
know I need help and I think as long as
you can be accepted that you're not the
greatest you're not the best you are
gonna need help it's yeah I like that so
just two more things that I just wanted
to chat to you about Jane before we
finish
so obviously back to sort of a big
motivator if you've been want to learn
more about recruitment retained these
types of things have you done that
have you been winning more retained
imagine what I said no so so let's just
talk about this for a sec going from
where you was mmm to getting more
involved in learning more about it
winning it pitching it what what's the
sort of main sort of difference that you
had to overcome or understand or do you
not I mean to start winning more
retained work because I think though I
work with someone and you have
critters win will retain work and I've
got a bit of an insight into the sort of
common challenges and misconceptions
that recruiters have on going from
contingent to win and retained if that's
not full II believing that there's a
difference or not fully believing that
they can deliver or whatever so what
were some of the things that you learn
or how to overcome or change slightly in
some of them mentally or the way fall
about things that helped you transition
yeah well what you're not doing it
before I to learn that recruiting wasn't
just contingent base I'm stuffed yeah
that's fair because you have nothing
else to compare it to it's very very
different yeah and so I'd say the key
thing is just mindset you need to change
your mindset you need to be a lot more
open to different solutions you need to
know that not one glove fits all so I
think the key thing is as well because
it's a self belief thing as well with
with your mindset you need to truly
value your benefit over absolutely most
a lot of a cruise I told see they don't
actually funny I know you mean yes I
know you mean like and I've been there
right I I remember not you know again
early days if I'm honest you may be in a
few years ago I think if I had if I was
a director of a company would I use
would I use an agent see I used to think
you know and that's just ridiculous
yeah you have to truly out yesterday I
learned that right and you have to truly
understand the actual value that you're
bringing here so I'd say that was crude
the biggest thing that we had to get
your head around yeah absolutely
and do you know what once I've learned
these things I then have to kind of
present this to my team and you know
there's been quite a few retain this one
quite a few retain this one since we've
started doing this training so like I
say all it is in mind that but if you
don't ask the question you never gonna
get the result just yeah what's the
worst that can happen
yeah oh you you get it on a contingent
basis nightmare that's what you would
have got anyway okay so
absolutely okay now that's interest in
and then
brand
how much does that actually help j gu
made the billet the building manager I
mean how do you evaluate that I think I
would say from from a psychological
perspective right
when I joined digital gears I thought
I've got this wicked brand behind me to
know what everyone's gonna want to work
me that was my mindset yeah and it
worked all right now was it down to the
brand I don't know I think it certainly
would have felt but yeah I mean forget
what the actual outward-facing branding
is right if you think you're the bee's
knees because your brand then that's the
most I'm happy because you know yeah
absolutely
then how you don't approach people did
having that company brand than you being
confident in it then I don't know did
you find it having impacts on the open
enough accounts or speaking to people or
like did it did it help you in that
sense I felt it did yeah yeah and I
can't say for sure that that's the
reason why but it made me feel like it
did absolutely and you know I know a lot
of businesses I'll talk about events has
been dead in the recruiting world like
organize everyone done may it's so wrong
why do you do events before Oscar no no
it's something I think it's something we
looked into how is that hot you then
because you looked completely right I've
had quite a few people talk about the
impact of running events hosting events
they're sort of a valuable to their
niche and I think it'd be it is really
easy for a cruise if they're now they've
been done no way like yes what what what
how did it help you so although the name
the brand helps right having a meetup
group it's called digital no it's it's
probably one of if not the most popular
tech meetup groups in Manchester okay
now that's an amazing
strapline in this yeah that's right but
I think the beauty behind is no one
really knows and already carrots that
we're recruiting business behind it
that's running it and because we do not
talk about recruitment you know a lot of
people said I'll we events we use that
for BD mmm no and and and that's
probably why our event does so well and
why we've got such a good name attached
to us because we're not what they think
is failing so ok no it does I think I
mean for me the conversations I've had
Jay and I hopefully agree you won't
disagree ten times that we don't talk
about a cream this is all about get sort
of developers in the room and then we
try get as many business cards as
possible but what it does mean is that
you can ring fifteen and [ __ ] cry and
say look my name is Jay guna what for
digital gurus I'm not trying to speak
about your hand requirements on and
talked about digital North alright ok
it's having a bit more yeah how open you
be to being the speaker 100 developers
on the common room will talk about the
versed in in in digital yeah I'll be
open to that Jay like I think the main
benefit that from the conversations I
have and why I think is so powerful is
that you can speak to people and build
relationships and lead without
recruitment yeah and I think that's a
very important point actually like I
think we can sometimes look at recruit
in the very kind of tunnel vision like
recruit me is part of much much much
bigger picture yeah so I think you have
to remember that when you're trying to
approach close and in some instances and
you know I've absolutely one business
off the back of these events absolutely
and but it's also good for I guess
account development perspective because
you're also putting your current clients
up on the stage put them into debates in
situations where they might get apps
right again that's relationships back to
you
yeah okay so Jay what what some so all
this experience this journey what would
be what's been the sort of toughest
challenge for you over the last four to
eight weeks mate
in the hospital right away yeah will
obviously look we can obviously had your
your little man banging on the door like
what what what what
he over the last for eight weeks made a
few person there yeah me personally look
I'm a people person in the day and you
know I I need to be around people I'm a
lot of a team a lot to see him grow I've
just you know it's not quite a same for
the screen is it it's not it's not you
know it's obviously we've already had
the relationship before we see each
other on a screen yeah that's cool but
yes it just takes it just takes
something away from your a little bit
doesn't it and you know sometimes a bit
of face time the client bit of face time
with the prospect gets things loading
line and I think not being able to do
that and present some challenges
absolutely but generally yeah it's
getting that face on the people this is
good you know video with you know we do
what a minimum of two team chats a day
and we do a kickoff and in the catch-up
and then we do individual and seem quite
as well so we do get a lot of face time
I think it's pretty cool and just mental
health perspectives but ultimately
there's nothing better than you know
yeah yeah
how have you a bit a big challenge from
from a management perspective in this
period has been like yeah keeping their
teams motivated it's just a bit
different isn't it how have you gone
about that so you just mentioned that
you have certain touch points per day or
every couple of days of your team but if
you've done anything that you found
being quite effective or found that sort
of helps keep the morale motivation high
of your team yeah I mean there's only so
much you can do and but you know we have
incentives that run so I think was it
last ride it and we deliver some peace
to someone the Haiti of course
little things like that unfortunately I
can't send you to to Nando's at the
minute you know Domino's will I'm sure
we hit the spot but yeah I think just
just things like that understanding
people situations again everyone's
different so I've got a couple of people
but honestly are absolutely fine and
they're embracing working from home and
they're loving it I've got other people
that are really struggling and and it's
just you have to try
little bit differently yeah and you know
this this always officer support from me
I'm happy to go out get the shopping go
deliberate for them no issues but yeah I
think you're somewhat limited in terms
of what you can and cannot do and what
how do you think this pier is gonna
impact recruiters recruitment as a whole
Jay when you think about that once
you've been in the industry for a while
as you start bouncing back out of this
what how do you see no one knows but how
what's of opportunities or how do you
think about the future of Jay the
recruiter and what the opportunities are
in the industry that's a big question I
think for the industry it's going to
become a lot more flexible but in a
right way because I'm a massive believer
in now we will need to be a half a for
this kickoff me in and we've got this
incentive right we'll need to be here
together to do that but yeah we're a
relatively flexible business anyway but
I think moving forwards we're gonna see
a lot more recruiting businesses and
they always staff to work more remotely
yeah and I know a lot of CEOs and in
deeds are very kind
I guess worried and being paranoid about
the data on there and they databases
there's some potential issues but you
know what we've had what three months of
it now three months of it
yeah I think they might have come down
to it so I think we'll probably see a
bit of a difference from that
perspective and again you look at it
banging on the door like he's the police
a minute I think I think I think people
are gonna be a lot more accepting of you
know you've got things going on at home
you can still have a serious business
crime say or the shirts I mean I can't
believe you're not mention my hair
become a lot more understanding and so
you know I think there's definitely a
time the place to wear a three-piece
suit okay I love putting on a
three-piece suit but I think people and
businesses and them become a lot more
relaxed because we've all seen each
other are worse now is gonna be
interested in and select Jay two last
questions firstly what was Jay most
excited about sort of after covet
we're most excited to do most excited to
see I don't know what you're most
excited about after Co vid me well you
know what we've we've been doing quite
well during this coin your periods you
know we work in technology which is
still I won't call it a booming industry
but it's a very very strong industry
right now and so with that figure is a
good so when we come out of this
I dare say nobody system reinvestment
let's grow the team let's let's go to
different places let's check out new
markets I'm so for us the future is
extremely bright and there's been a lot
of things that we've learnt and about
each other in this time so again this is
going to help with not so much promotion
but understand what people fit within a
business so I familiar and you've seen a
lot of benefits coming out of this but I
think if you're talking about an
industry I think your contract work
really is going to go through the roof
then when people start hiring again
and she live white because I don't think
they'll take the risk on maybe taking
permanent employees really that's yes
it's just what I think it's what you
know so yeah I think there'll be a bit
of a kick in the contract market and
initially a bit a knee-jerk reaction
hopefully the kids and it's not too much
going around right now but yeah I think
good things are going to happen and I
think just with the whole working in the
home situation I I think done
technically but one of the biggest and
most annoying things that you hear in
employing business is sorry we've got no
flexibility you can't work from home
it's like how developer not work may and
that was one of the biggest motor that
was one of the biggest frustrations
wasn't then for love technology so so
now there's no excuse for it yeah mrs.
clients you're going to have to adhere
to it instead of thing I think now at
that experience there and they've been
forced into it that we're now unable to
say it's force people's hand wasn't that
last question you can answer the phrase
a word a sentence whatever comes up Jay
but if J goon a could communicate to
every single recruit out there they'd
listen they'd implement your advice what
would you say to the people that
question
I I would say the times right now are
that they're different
yeah they present different challenges
just adapt to it be open to different
ways of working continue to grow your
relationships and I think now is a
recipe for you to come out this other
side and be a much better recruiter and
stay motivated remember why you're doing
this job you're gonna have your ship
days that's why we will have them but
remember there are things you can do
that can pick you straight back up again
go and call those ten clients that you
have a laugh with go and call him right
have a laugh of him call me I don't care
all right and then get back on that get
back on that boat and you go again and
that's what I say always remember that
angle Jay it's been a pleasure mate
thank you know if I see him I'm a place
speaking to